I'm James Hoffman an author and coffee
expert and I'm here to answer your
questions from Twitter this is coffee
support
[Music]
first up black horse cough asks caffeine
myths dark versus light does the type of
roast affect how much caffeine is in
coffee this is a really good question
let me get some dark and light roasts
for you
now a lot of interesting stuff happens
in The Roasting process with a lighter
roasted coffee technically speaking more
of the caffeine that was in the raw
coffee is still in the coffee to get a
darker roast the coffee spends more time
in the roasting drum and it gets up to
the kind of temperatures where caffeine
sublimates it goes from a solid to a gas
which is kind of interesting but this is
the important thing this coffee is
denser and if I took 10 grams of this
coffee in 10 grams of this coffee
there'd be more beans to make up the 10
grams if I was using the darker roast so
while I might be less caffeine per Bean
I'd be using more beans and so
ultimately the amount of caffeine will
vary a lot more by the type of coffee
being roasted whether it's Arabica or a
buster whether it's high grown or low
grown the roast itself is not something
you really need to worry about Robin
Jerry Lee asks is there any good instant
coffee there is there is good instant
coffee now for a long time there was not
instant coffee the point of instant
coffee was cheap cheap coffee and that
applied to the raw coffee going into it
these days there are good specialty
coffee is being turned into instant
coffees but really the difference is
down to the raw materials by putting
good raw coffee well roasted into the
whole process you get a surprisingly
good result out Allison D rush asks how
do coffee beans grow decaffeinated good
question coffee does not grow
decaffeinated coffee trees actually
produce caffeine as a form of insect
repellent the higher you grow coffee the
less caffeine it needs to produce
because the less insects there are now
when we decaffeinate coffee there's
actually a process that's done after
harvest but before the coffee is roasted
and there's a bunch of different ways to
decaffeinate coffee some of which have
very nice sounding names like Swiss
water process others have terrifying
names like ethyl acetate But ultimately
all decaf processes are very safe and
generally have to remove 99.5 of the
caffeine from coffee to be certified as
decaf however they are now starting to
experiment with new varieties of coffee
that are naturally very low in caffeine
so keep an eye out for those those don't
need decaffeination and they'll have way
way lower levels of caffeine than normal
coffee let's see what's next the pour
over blog asks what to the ideal
temperature for coffee that's a good
question it has a bunch of different
answers because I don't know what point
you're talking if you're talking about
brewing coffee then generally speaking
close to Boiling Point is the right
temperature for water for brewing coffee
if you're talking about drinking coffee
that's a very different answer now the
interesting thing is very hot coffee
doesn't taste as good as coffee getting
closer to kind of body temperature when
coffee goes from hot to kind of
enjoyably warm it starts to taste much
much much much better and so letting
your coffee cool down a little bit
before you drink it gives you a more
complex more interesting experience
ultimately because you as a human you're
just not very good at tasting stuff
that's a long way away from body
temperature jnk vmk asks does anyone
know how to make espresso without
machine LMAO okay I have to do it I have
to just cover this quickly the drink is
technically espresso not espresso a
large fraction of the internet will get
very angry with you for using the wrong
one I'm not one of those and actually in
France it is the correct term it is
espresso in France anyway espresso is
interesting you can't really make it
without a machine because of what
defines it as espresso now espresso
machines are really expensive because
they do a bunch of stuff in terms of
temperature and pressure and all that
kind of stuff but if you just wanted to
make really good but really really
strong coffee there are a couple of bits
of coffee kit though that can make
really delicious strong coffee let me
show you what I mean I love both of
these and they're very different but
they can both make really strong coffee
this is an Aeropress it's super cheap
indestructible 20 25 worth having a
grade to travel with and this is the
time ordered Classic this is a mocha pot
or a stovetop Brewer both of these can
make really strong coffee and buy a sort
of strong coffee I'd be anything from
almost espresso strength of like one
part coffee to three parts water up to a
kind of traditional mocha pop Brew of
one part coffee to 10 parts water or if
you have a way to foam milk at home you
can make a delicious kind of homemade
cappuccino and Kaya next door asks what
about coffee makes me have to dookie
like I don't understand that part it is
weird it's kind of weird that when you
drink coffee that can happen really
quickly like like really quickly there's
no way that it will worked its way
through your digestive tract all the way
down and then made the magic happen so
science doesn't truly understand what's
going on the sort of main theory is that
it actually triggers a hormone response
so when you drink coffee your body
releases a hormone and that's what
triggers the need to run to the bathroom
with great speed at sleepy Lyra asks why
do people put milk and sugar in their
tea and coffee especially sugar like
calm down and learn to love the bitter
and not alter and change what the drink
is supposed to be it's a good point
there's a lot of reasons to put milk in
coffee and mostly they are the coffee
tastes bad now milk is going to add a
little bit of sweetness to that drink
that's definitely going to help but milk
does another very cool thing it acts as
a bitter blocker so when you've got
harsh bitter coffee sugar doesn't
actually decrease bitterness you can add
a little bit of salt and actually if
your coffee is really bitter a tiny
pinch of salt is a wonderful thing but
milk comes in and actually masks some of
the bitterness and that's partly the
sort of proteins of the milk and also
the fat in the milk too which will give
it a kind of nicer texture and mouth
feel as for tea yeah I don't know I
don't I don't really get milk and sugar
and tea either so I'm with you at impact
pod asks the Timeless question what's
the difference between hashtag cold brew
and hashtag iced coffee this is a big
one and and this is where people really
divide into camps especially on the
internet so cold brew is cold coffee
made with cold or room temperature water
that means you have to steep it for a
really long time because cold water
isn't very good at pulling the flavors
out of the grounds iced coffee is hot
coffee made strong and then rapidly
chilled by Brewing directly onto iced
that way you tend to get all of the
complexity of the sort of the coffee
because it was brewed with hot water but
you get a nice chilled delicious
beverage at the end of it cold brew is
generally less kind of complex and
interesting and has a kind of cold brew
taste that some people really like and
other people especially those who work
in the coffee industry tend to identify
as a slightly oxidized and stale taste
in coffee and they get very angry about
cold brew however a lot of people think
cold brew is better for their stomachs
they like the taste if you enjoy cold
brew enjoy cold brew but if you really
love cold coffee I would recommend at
least trying iced coffee TS Organics
asks what climate is best for growing
coffee the best climate for coffee has a
couple of really important things it has
warm sunny days and then cool evenings
you tend to find that at higher
altitudes the lower altitudes will get
lots of sun but they won't have the cool
evenings the reason you want this kind
of diurnal swing as they call it between
days and nights is that you want to feed
the the fruit of the tree with loads of
sunshine but then you want cool night to
slow the maturation process that gives
you a denser coffee seed and more
complex ultimately cup of coffee at the
end of it so the best most valued most
kind of delicious coffees tend to come
from countries that have tons of very
high altitude from Colombia or Panama or
Costa Rica Ethiopia Kenya countries like
that then you also have these weird
little sort of exceptions to the rule
which are called Island coffee so places
like Hawaii where you have less altitude
but because it's an island and you get
the cool Sea Breeze coming in the
evenings you get this kind of matching
climate where you have warm sunny days
and cool nights on to the next one lab
splaining asks okay I have an important
question for coffee drinkers how much
coffee do you put in your coffee what's
your grounds to water ratio because
apparently compared to my friends I
drink pure Rocket Fuel so now I'm
curious firstly when it comes to Coffee
to water ratios there's no correct
answer it's basically preference but
there are some guidelines that work for
most people I would recommend people
Brew 60 grams of coffee per liter of
water or if you turn it back into a
ratio one part coffee to 16 Parts water
but it could be 15 to 17. that's the
kind of rough area there to help you
with this I would strongly recommend a
kitchen scale like this one the reason I
like these is that I'm usually making
coffee before I've had coffee and I
don't really want to think about the
coffee making process but if I know just
how much coffee to put in how much water
to put in I'll get it right every single
time and I'll be very kind to myself so
these cheap essential good for cooking
get a set of scales Philip Brown asks
does grinding your own coffee beans make
much of a difference to the taste it
makes a huge difference to The Taste if
there was one thing that I could sort of
make everyone in the world do it would
be grind their own coffee beans fresh it
is delightful they smell amazing and
your drink tastes so much better I feel
like almost everyone owns a pepper
grinder you're willing to do like a
little bit of work for a tiny component
of one dish and coffee that's the only
ingredient and you get all the benefits
it tastes better more complex more
delicious more enjoyable and you get the
smell I said like extra bonus grinding
your own coffee is a wonderful thing
satnam asks there's no real difference
between a latte flat white and
cappuccino is there we're just humoring
them no no there's a difference they all
have different histories and and they
have some key differences in terms of
strength as well as texture a latte is
is probably the weakest of the drinks
there it's a Milky coffee it might have
a thin layer of foam conversely a
cappuccino should be a much stronger
drink it should have a nice thick
moussey layer of foam on top if it's
good now the flat white The antibiian
Invention lives between those two things
it's the texture of a latte but the
strength of a cappuccino in terms of
histories the oldest drink by far is the
cappuccino and it's not Italian it's
Austrian back then it was called and
caputsina and it was just black coffee
and milk mixed to the color of the
Capuchin Monk's robes which is very
specific Caffe Latte really is kind of
an American invention that sort of
happened when coffee spread outside of
Italy latte macchiato exists in Italy
maybe but the flat white that's
antibodyian and they argue the kiwis and
the Aussies about who invented it we
don't know but that's their invention
probably in the 1990s Bob Hyatt asked
okay coffee snobs help me in my
ignorance the difference between drip
coffee and pour over coffee is well not
that much in terms of the finished drink
they're the same thing it's kind of down
to how they're made if you see pour over
in a cafe that's probably an
individually made cup of coffee where
you have something like a cone uh coffee
inside and someone's pouring water over
the top of it drip is kind of the
category of filter coffee and it can
come from a batch Brew it can come from
a pour over a Mr Coffee at home that's
all making drip coffee pour over is just
like the fancy subset within drip coffee
van vicious asks I was thinking that
maybe siphon for coffee brewing works
the same like a bone eh hashtag bong
coffee
weed can't speak to Bong usage but I
will show you how a siphon works because
it is a lot of fun gonna need a few
different bits for this though this is
the fanciest way to heat a siphon this
is a halogen light heater and then this
is a siphon and it works in a lovely way
it's a nice science demonstration we're
going to start with putting some hot
water in the base of this thing start to
get it hot
and then we're going to put this piece
in here because these little balls here
act as a nucleation point if you boil
water in a smooth vessel you can
actually super heat the water and and
that's bad don't do that so once the
water starts to boil we'll put this top
piece on that will create a seal in this
bottom chamber and as the water boils it
creates Steam and that steam is going to
expand and push the water through the
tube up into this top section here where
we can add coffee and we can Brew so
this is clever because even though this
water is boiling hot this water isn't
boiling hot and it's kind of a nice
temperature for brewing coffee so you
can reduce the heat a little bit here
and then we're going to add our coffee
give it a little mix all those grounds
to be nice and wet
now this is one of the most enjoyable
Brews to sort of smell as you go at the
start
smells kind of harsh and piny and
resinous and after about a minute it
will start to smell really sweet and you
kind of know the Brew is pretty much
done and at the end of The Brew this is
the fun bit when you turn off the heat
here that steam is going to start to
cool and it'll start to contract and it
will create a kind of negative pressure
that will start to suck the grounds and
the water through the filter will end up
with our delicious brewed coffee down at
the bottom here
and you're ready to pour and enjoy your
siphon brewed coffee guaranteed to
impress your friends though not
something you want to do every morning
perfect daily G asks full immersion or
filter coffee what's your favorite now
this refers to the kind of two big
schools of coffee brewing that are out
there let me show you examples of each
one you've got full immersion and that's
like a French press where all of the
coffee and all the water hang out
together for a while and then you
separate and strain them versus filtered
coffee that's usually more of a
percolation and there you're pouring
water onto a bed of coffee and the water
is sort of passing through and
percolating through it and these can be
a little bit more difficult to get right
these are very easy ways to make a
coffee and so I love a French press for
being really really simple effortless
and a wonderful way to brew almost any
coffee really well so from an ease
perspective definitely love full emotion
brewing a question from at fizz LOL or
B4 can you eat raw coffee beans I mean
you can you shouldn't don't chew them
they're really hard raw cough is much
much harder it's a plant seed and it's
quite big it's about the size of a
peanut so don't chew it you might crack
a tooth but if you ingest it yeah it's
just going to pass right through you
that's what seeds are designed to do so
you know some people have chosen to
drink the results don't do that don't do
that coffee fruit however if you get the
chance to eat fresh coffee fruit from a
tree is delicious they look like grapes
but they're mostly seed and they're kind
of Tangy watermelony delicious little
fruits definitely eat those David
alvarezi asks who invented coffee I want
to kiss you but after this poop I just
had coffee this is a great question
because we don't know it's really
interesting we kind of have no idea of
this really important moment in
Humanity's history we know that people
were drinking coffee in the 15th century
in and around Yemen and the Arabian
Peninsula and we know that before that
in Ethiopia where the sort of Coffee
Tree first flourished people were eating
coffee fruit from the tree but this
moment where someone was like I'm gonna
take the seeds from this fruit squeeze
them out I'm going to dry them then I'm
gonna I'm gonna roast them then I'm
gonna smash them to little pieces then
I'm going to put it in hot water and
then I'm going to drink that hot water
that moment of Genius we have no idea
when and where that happened Tommy Udo
asks is it possible or desirable to
roast your own coffee beans at home in a
domestic gas oven well it's possible I
would not say it's desirable I have a
little bit of raw coffee here
that's raw coffee it's pale it's green
it's a very dense plant seed now the
roasting process is where a bunch of
magic happens it's where it goes from
tasting like a plant to tasting like a
delicious cup of coffee you can do it in
an oven but that coffee won't roast
evenly the bits in contact with your
baking sheet will sort of roast a lot
faster because the convection of the air
and the conduction of the pan itself a
commercial roaster will constantly churn
and toss and move the coffee around to
make sure that it's roasting evenly and
uneven roasts tend to taste harsh bitter
charcoal and a little bit burnt but it
can be done and people do do it so feel
free to experiment but I warn you if you
think coffee is a weird hobby coffee
roasting is is far more of a terrifying
rabbit hole at Darren Shaw asks should
you freeze your coffee beans and I would
say yes yes you should freeze your
coffee beans if you're going to store
them for a long time if you've got way
too much coffee in the house and you're
not going to get through it in the next
few weeks package it up sort of airtight
that's kind of important and then freeze
it it'll keep a really long time in the
freezer you can grab find from Frozen
but I wouldn't recommend kind of opening
a bag and pulling out a handful of beans
at a time if you're going to sort of
brew a bag pull it out you can defrost
it it's fine you can use it from Frozen
that first time it doesn't really matter
but freezing the coffee beans is
definitely a very good thing don't
bother putting them in the fridge don't
put ground coffee in the fridge that
doesn't really slow down the Sterling
process and you can kind of
cross-contaminate you can make your food
smell of coffee and your coffee smell
like the food in your fridge so freezer
is good cupboard is okay fridge is bad
in it ink asks why are they putting
Nitro in my coffee what's happening well
they're doing it for two reasons firstly
it looks really cool you get that kind
of Guinness effect a kind of nice foamy
head it looks beautiful and then they're
doing it for the same reason that kind
of beer does it in that it adds some
really nice texture to the finished
drink you end up drinking this kind of
black coffee that somehow almost creamy
like a cappuccino that's mostly it I
think beer pioneered this stuff and
coffee was like we can use the same
equipment and do the same thing and the
results are pretty fun so a very common
question from Food Express Inc is coffee
actually good for for you and I think we
can say with a decent degree of
certainty yes yes coffee is good for you
now there's a load of different studies
done on coffee and and we've got good
data saying coffee is good for the
microbiome it contains a surprising
amount of fiber coffee is good for your
heart we see reductions in heart disease
as well as arrhythmias there's lots of
supporting evidence from loads of
different studies around the world that
says Coffee drinkers live longer but and
this is a really important but that
doesn't mean you should just drink as
much coffee as you want the moment that
coffee starts to interrupt or disrupt
your sleep that's too much coffee and
it's now bad for you again so that's the
sort of Line in the Sand the minute you
start to struggle to go to sleep or have
decreased Sleep Quality that's when you
need to dial back your caffeine
consumption coffee fiend ma asks what is
the difference between hashtag coffee
and hashtag espresso espresso is a very
small very strong cup of coffee brewed
from incredibly finely ground coffee
under high pressure at high temperatures
so it's like an intense extract of
coffee typically it's brewed at nine
bars of pressure which may not mean much
to anyone about 100 130 PSI and you do
that because when you grow in the coffee
really really really fine you need to
sort of push the water to be able to get
it through the coffee now I've got some
samples of grounds here espresso ground
coffee it's not quite flower fine but if
you sort of pinch it it will retain its
shape it's really pretty fine whereas
for drip it's more like a coarser sugar
kind of thing you can feel much bigger
pieces between your fingers and with
espresso you're going to use a lot less
water because you need less water
because there's a lot more flavor
exposed in the grounds by grinding them
so finely so that's the definition of
espresso a small amount of liquid tons
of coffee flavor brewed Under Pressure
which also gives it a lovely red Brown
foam on top called chroma and it must be
done under those High pressures at Katie
business 33 asks I think I burnt my
coffee is that even a thing and the
answer would be maybe it depends how you
think you burn your coffee if you think
you burn your coffee by putting boiling
water on it and you've got a kind of
burnt harsh taste no you didn't burn it
that flavor is just in the coffee
already and the very hot water extracted
the flavor out of it however if you
think you burnt it by putting it on a
hot plate for half an hour an hour then
yes you kind of did you kind of cooked
it you generated a bunch of new tastes
in the liquid and yeah it's going to
taste harsh bitter and present and then
yes you did burn your coffee Marcia
Harold asks I have a question since I'm
not a parent at what age do you start
letting kids drink coffee there's not
like a rule here there's actually no
real guidance uh I read at one point
schooled in Brazil were giving coffee to
children to help them concentrate in
math lessons kids as young as nine so
you know from a from a biology
perspective nothing particularly bad is
going to happen but if you have a
traumatic bedtime most evenings I
suspect giving your children caffeine is
not a very good idea young salami boy
asks mistakenly got sugar in my coffee
absolutely disgusting who does this a
lot of people put sugar in coffee now
sugar doesn't reduce bitterness but a
lot of bad coffee can also be quite sour
and at that point sugar is kind of
making things a little bit better the
way that sugar makes lemon into lemonade
so sugar does balance out acidity make
the whole thing more enjoyable and
ultimately a little sugar helps the
medicine go down but if your coffee is
good to start with if it's well brewed
if it's you know fresh it should have a
nice natural sweetness it shouldn't be
dominantly acidic or bitter then then
sugar kind of makes it all kind of out
of sorts out of balance and it does
indeed ruin it so good coffee needs no
sugar but if you like a little sugar in
your coffee because you like sweet
things then go right ahead at mollywood
asks why does coffee taste gross when
you microwave it and it's not just
microwaves if you reheat coffee from say
cold back to kind of hot again what
you're doing is feeding in a bunch of
energy and getting a bunch of chemistry
going again and that chemistry generates
new flavor compounds those are often
quite harsh astringent and bitter and so
you just want to avoid reheating coffee
sadly if it's gone cold there's not much
you can do to make it taste good again
VidCon asks how many cups of coffee a
day is too much and this is a difficult
one to answer I'll give you what we know
there is a guideline from most places
saying for caffeine consumption 200 to
300 milligrams a day is your recommended
dose that's great except you have no
idea how much caffeine is in the
particular cup of coffee that you're
drinking and two competing businesses
will sell let's say two cappuccinos that
will have wildly different amounts of
caffeine been in them in addition to
this there is a genetic component some
people are fast caffeine metabolizers
some people are slow caffeine
metabolizers so generally speaking for
most types of coffee out there three or
four cups a day is probably fine unless
it's messing with your sleep some people
can drink more and feel absolutely fine
they can have a double espresso after
dinner and go straight to sleep they are
the fortunate for you but for most
people three four cups a day I would say
it is a good sort of level to aim at at
aimer Anna asks what makes Turkish
coffee has this strong spice taste to it
well the strong bit is is how you grind
coffee for Turkish Brewing you grind it
almost as fine as flour so it's going to
be very strong because you're going to
get all the flavor out of those grounds
secondly it is not unusual to add spices
to the pot as you're Brewing cardamom is
very common and that will obviously give
it a delicious sort of spicy twist add
salt grumpy asks Irish whiskey in my
coffee good for a cough suppressor right
I can't speak to that aspect of it if
that works for you that's great it is
delicious though I think whiskey and
coffee are totally good friends and not
just Irish whiskey always whiskey eat
some coffee I think can play very nicely
recommended if you haven't tried it and
finally akshar asks what happened to
dalgona Coffee you're moved on so quick
well they let us go outside again I
think that was a key part of this dog
owner blew up during the pandemic when
we were stuck inside and it involved
things that most people had at home it
was instant coffee sugar and a little
bit of water a whisk and spare time we
all had those things and I think dog
owner was the perfect coffee treat for
the time however as fun as it is it's
not particularly delicious and I think
once we could start going to cafes again
and enjoying the great coffee scene we
wanted to do that all right those are
the questions that was coffee support I
hope you learned something I hope you're
in the mood to go and brew a cup of
coffee and enjoy it thanks so much for
watching I hope you have a great day